يعتزم الديمقراطيون في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي طرح تشريع للتصويت من شانه تضمين
انشاء دوله فلسطينيه كجزء من حزمه الامن
القومي التي تشمل المساعدات العسكريه
لاسرائيل فقد وقع 49 من 51 ديمقراطيا في
مجلس الشيوخ على مشروع قانون لادخال تعديل
على ملحق الامن القومي الامريكي ويؤكد ان
سياسه الولايات المتحده هي دعم الحل
الشامل عن طريق التفاوض للصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني ويؤدي الى انشاء دولتين وهو ما
قد يعني ربط المساعدات الامنيه الامريكيه
لاسرائيل بموافقه حكومتها على رؤيه
السياسه
الامريكيه معنا من واشنطن مراسلنا محمد
العالمي اهلا بك محمد ما هي اصداء هذا
التشريع الجديد في مرحلته
الحاليه
اصداء ربما مفاجئه لانها مريم خطوه غير
مسبوقه هذا المجلس الذي امامي و بغرفتيه
النواب والشيوخ ذب خلال العقود الاخيره ان
يختلف حول كل شيء الا موضوع اسرائيل والان
نرى الاغلبيه الساحقه من الديمقراطيين
باستثناء عضوين في مجلس الشيوخ يربطون
المساعدات لاسرائيل لاوكرانيا وتايوان
بضروره التزام اسرائيل بحل الدولتين في
مجلس النواب ايضا 15 عضوا من اليهودي
الامريكيين وقعوا رساله اكدوا فيها على
ان حل الدولتين هو السبيل المنشود في هذه
القضيه المقترح الذي سيرتبط ب بمشروع
قانون مثير للجدل اصلا ويتعثر في مجلس
الشيوخ منذ اكتوبر الماضي حينما اقترح
الرئيس جو بايدن مساعده لاسرائيل ب 14
مليار دولار لكن تاخر التصديق عليه لاسباب
لا علاقه لها باسرائيل من قبيل اصرار
الجمهوريين على ربطه ببناء الور وحمايه
الحدود الامريكيه من المهاجرين وهو امر
يرفضه الى حد ما معظم
الديمقراطيين بعض الجمهوريين ضون تقديم
مساعدات لاوكرانيا وكل هذا عطل موضوع
مساعده لاسرائيل ايضا ومن شان هذا التعلل
ان يؤخر ايضا الاجماع على موضوع تايوان
واوكرانيا و واسرائيل لكن المثير في هذه
الخطوه ان من يتزعمها يهود امريكيون وانضم
اليهم جميع اعضاء الطيف الايديولوجي داخل
الحزب الديمقراطي من اشد المؤيدين
لاسرائيل الى اكبر منتقدين فيها كما هو
الشان بالنسبه للسناتور برني ساندرز
الرساله واضحه اولا للبيت الابيض دعم موقف
جوزيف بايدن الرئيس الذي قدم دعما غير
مسبوق لاسرائيل ومع ذلك يتحداه رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي علنا في موضوع
الدولتين ورساله ربما اقوى واوضح لرئيس
الوزراء نفسه ان هذا الدعم غير مشروط
لامريكا قد يصبح مشروطا ان لم يرضخ
للمطالب الام
بشان الدولتين محمد العلمي من واشنطن شكرا
جزيلا لك